we're asked to mark all the relative
extremum points in the graph below so
pause the video and see if you can have
a go at that just try to maybe look at
the screen and in your head see if you
can identify the relative extrema
so now let's do this together so there's
two types of relative extrema you have
your relative maximum points and you
have your relative
minimum points
and a relative maximum point or a
relative minimum they're relatively easy
to to spot out visually
you will see a relative maximum point as
the high point on a hill and the hill
itself doesn't even have to be the
highest hill for example the curve could
go at other parts of the domain of the
function could go to higher values
it could also look like the peak of a
mountain and once again since we're
talking about the relative maxima this
mountain peak doesn't have to be the
highest mountain peak there could be
higher mountains and actually each of
these peak each of these peaks would be
a relative maximum point
now relative minima are the opposite
they would be the bottom of your valleys
so that's a relative minimum point
this right over here is a relative
minimum point even if there are other
parts of the function that are lower
now there's also an edge case for both
relative maxima and relative minima and
that's where the graph is flat so
if you have parts of your function where
it's just constant these points would
actually be both for example if this is
our x-axis right over here
that's our x-axis if this is our
y axis right over there and if this is x
equals c if you construct an open
interval around c you notice that the
value of our function at c f of c is at
least as large as the values of the
function around it and it is also at
least as small as the values of the
function around it so this point would
also be considered a relative minimum
point but that's an edge case that you
won't encounter as often so with that
primer out of the way let's identify the
relative extrema
so first the relative maximum points
well that's the top of a hill right over
there
this is the top of a hill you might be
tempted to look at that point at that
point but notice at this point right
over here if you go to the right you
have values that are higher than it so
it's really not at the top of a hill and
right over here if you go to the left
you have values to the that are higher
than it so it's also not the top of a
hill
and what about the relative minimum
points well this one right over here is
a relative minimum point
this one right over here is a relative
minimum point
and this one over here is a relative
minimum point now let's do an example
dealing with absolute extrema
so here we're told to mark the absolute
maximum and the absolute minimum points
in the graph below so once again pause
this video and see if you can have a go
at this
so you have an absolute maximum
point
at let's say x equals c
if
and only if so i'll write if for if and
only if
f of c
is greater than or equal to f of x for
all the x's in the domain of the
function and you have an absolute
minimum
at
x equals c
if and only if if
f of c
is less than or equal to
f of x for all the x's over the domain
so another way to think about it is the
absolute maximum point is the high point
so over here that is the absolute
maximum point and then the absolute
minimum point is interesting because in
this case it would be actually one of it
would happen at one of the end points at
our domain so that is our absolute
max
and this right over here is our absolute
absolute min
now once again there is an edge case
that you will not see too frequently so
for example if this function did
something like this so if it went up
like this
and then it just stayed flat
then this would no longer be an absolute
maximum point but any of these points in
this flat region because they're at
least as high as any other points on our
entire curve
any of those could be considered
absolute maximum points but we aren't
dealing with that edge case in this
example and you're less likely to see
that and so in most problems it's pretty
easy to pick out because the absolute
highest point of the curve will often be
your absolute maximum and the absolute
lowest point on your curve will be your
absolute minimum